بعد ان لجات روسيا لاسلحه جنوب افريقيا
لاحتداب معركه باخموت بحسب اتهامات غربيه
هذه المره تخطط روسيا لشحنها من مالي فمنذ
اكثر من عام سعد فاجنر الى توسيع شبكتها
في مالي وعلى ما يبدو ستدخلها خط الازمه
في اوكرانيا عن بعد مسؤول امريكي رجح ان
فاجنر تنقل معده عسكريه من مالي
لاستخدامها في حربها مع كييف ونقلا عن
معلومات استخباراتيه نشرتها
لم تنجح فاجنر في شراء العتاد من مالي
ولكن مساعيها نحو ذلك لا تتوقف الغام
وطائرات مسيره ورادارات وانظمه بطاريه
مضاده كلها كانت ضمن طلبات فاجنر التي
زورت اوراق معاملاتها وفق سي ان ان ما
يعني ان روسيا لم تتجه لنقل الاسلحه من
تركيا وكوريا الشماليه فحسب وانما تستغل
دول العالم الثالث لتمرير شحناتها
العسكريه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات